did i agree with what he said
no everybody goes if you support him
then you must be racist because he's
racist
i'm not racist neither is peace racist
on wednesday's episode of the talk
sharon osborne and her co-hosts
addressed the backlash facing the
68-year-old tv personality
since defending pierce morgan for his
decision to leave good morning britain
got a good chat with itv and we agreed
to disagree
as well as his comments about meghan
markle i'm sorry i don't believe a word
she says meghan markle
i wouldn't believe it if she read me a
weather report and the fact that she's
fired up
onslaught against our royal family i
think is contemptible
and now a source is telling et that the
ladies of the talk had a closed-door
meeting after filming wednesday's show
to discuss what happened on air but the
source adds
nothing was resolved if peop people know
you're not racist they would want you to
stand up to your friend
who has done racist things who has been
sexist
in the coverage of megan while you're
standing by your friend
it appears that you give validation or
safe haven
to something that he has uttered that is
racist i feel even like
i'm about to be put in the electric
chair because i have a friend
who many people think is a racist so
that makes me a racist
it all started on tuesday when sharon
tweeted that she stands by her friend
pierce
writing quote people forget that you're
paid for your opinion
and that you're just speaking your truth
you think you wear bits and parts a lot
of people are saying
no no i believe in freedom of speech
i believe in the right to be allowed to
have an opinion
well that tweet landed sharon in the hot
seat
he doesn't want to understand that how
megan was treated was racism that
white entitlement privilege that makes
it racist upon itself
once you say i stand by my friend then
then people think well then you must
agree with what he's saying
when we kind of give passes or give
space to people
who are who are being who are saying
damaging harmful things
what we're kind of doing is permissing
it and i think that's what people are
reacting to
sharon got visibly emotional during the
conversation
noting that she doesn't agree with
anything pierce did
or said but he's always been there for
her as a friend
and i think we should stop this and
don't try and cry because if anyone
should be
crying it should be me right now i'm
talking to
a woman who i believe is my friend and i
don't want anybody here
to to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being racist
i think it's anything late i think
that's already sewn
hours after the show sharon posted this
video of an
unbothered panda eating carrots
alongside the caption
wednesday one follower suggested that
she should have disabled her comments to
which
sharon replied quote never another
social media user posted a lengthy
message about
sharon's attitude on the show and how
her co-hosts were quote
trying to get you to understand from the
perspective of a black person
sharon's response i actually really
appreciate and respect this comment
your approach allows a lot of room to
listen
as for pierce he also responded to the
daytime talk show host
tweeting in part quote when stuff like
this happens
true friends run towards you fake
friends run away
i love sharon osbourne because she
always stays true to herself
[Music]
you